[BEAKER STIRRING]
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: It's day
two of 5.301.
The students are given a tenth
of a gram of Ethyl
3-hydroxybenzoate contaminated
with a small amount of
triethylamine.
The goal is to separate the
contaminant from the target
chemical using a technique
called extraction.
The students first dissolve
the mixture in ether, then
they add an acid solution.
Acid and ether don't mix,
so two layers form.
As the students shake the
mixture, the acid reacts with
the contaminant to
form a salt.
This salt is much less soluble
in ether than it is an acid,
so it moves from the
ether to the acid.
The two liquids separate
back into two layers.
Overall, the target molecule
stays in the ether and the
contaminant moves to
the acid layer.
ANTHONY: This has my product.
This has my impurity.
ANNOUNCER: Now it's time to head
over to the rotovap to
evaporate the ether.
Anthony starts rotovapping,
and it's all
going well, for now.
But after a while--
ANTHONY: I'm not getting
any of my dried
sample on the edges.
I think as long as there is
still ether in there, then I
won't get anything to show
up, is what I'm hoping.
IKE: His was a lot and
it's not succeeding.
Mine is little, so what
chance do I have?
ANTHONY: I thought I did
something wrong and, of
course, no one wants to do
anything wrong, especially on
the second day.
I should have gotten
some product.
I went to Tengfei, and I was
like, look lady, I don't know
you very well but this doesn't
seem like it's working.
She drained the solvent
and then turned
on the vacuum again.
I still don't see anything.
Everyone else was getting their
samples and they were
going to dry and then mass.
And I was like, I don't
have anything.
ANNOUNCER: Anthony's troubles
finally get Phil's attention.
PHIL: Try putting it on one
of the other rotovaps.
ANNOUNCER: Phil thinks the
rotovap Anthony is
using must be broken.
ANTHONY: And I start getting
crystals, I guess, on the side
of my round bottom.
I clutched my heart.
And I was like, finally.
ANNOUNCER: But the sample
doesn't quite look right, and
Tengfei has something
to say about that.
TENGFEI: Who's to know what
you are supposed to get?
ANTHONY: So she's
like, calm down.
Like, just hold on.
You don't even know what
you're supposed to get
yet, so hold on.
ANNOUNCER: Anthony runs
an NMR to figure out
exactly what he has.
ANTHONY: Check this out.
This doesn't look like
it's horribly wrong.
So, hopefully this will be it.
I think this is a pretty
good NMR scan.
ANNOUNCER: Even though his
sample looks different, the
NMR spectrum matches that
of the pure compound.
ANTHONY: 70% yield.
So not wonderful,
but not too bad.
When I got a sample and I got a
pretty big yield and it was
pretty pure, I was happy.
ANNOUNCER: And that's it.
The first day is done.
EMILY: Overall, I think
the lab was OK.
It was a little stressful at
times, but we all made it
though it alive and I think it
will just get easier with each
day as we become more
comfortable
with what we're doing.
ETHAN: I'm definitely not
as nervous anymore
to go to the lab.
I'm actually more excited
for it, I guess.
ANTHONY: I'm looking forward
to tomorrow.
It's going to be a lot harder,
but I think it's going to be a
lot of fun.
PHIL: I'm not a gambling man.
I do slot machines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]